اصيب سته عشر فلسطينيا بينهم صحفيون اثر
اطلاق قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الرصاصه
الحيه والمعدنيه على مئات الفلسطينيين في
مدينه رام الله خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات ما الرسائل التي تريد
اسرائيل توجيهها باقتحام مدينه رام الله
وما خيارات السلطه الفلسطينيه للتعامل مع
هذا الوضع في المرحله المقبله وكيف يبدو
موقف واشنطن راعيه السلام والمشرفه عن تلك
الاتفاقيات
الرساله واضحه وان اسرائيل تستخف بالجميع
تستخف للسلطه الفلسطينيه
وبكل من شاركوا في اجتماع شرم الشيخ وقبل
ذلك في اجتماع العقبه واسرائيل كل ما جرى
في شرم الشيخ مزقته ورمت به في سله
المهملات طبعا وتخطئ اكثر باستمرارها في
التنسيق الامني مع الجانب الاسرائيلي في
ظل هذا الاجرام الذي يمارس ضدها وضد الشعب
الفلسطيني نحن نتحدث عن مؤامره خطيره
تشنها اسرائيل وهذا يستدعي رد فعل مختلف
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
انا تخميني ان اسرائيل شاطره مع مسؤولين
الولايات المتحده خططها حقيقه ان ان هناك
اختلاف هذا بين مساعدات تقدمها الولايات
المتحده لاسرائيل
والمساعدات الولايات المتحده للسلطه
الفلسطينيه هذا لا لا يؤثر او لا يقل من
شان الالتزام الولايات المتحده بحل
الدولتين العقبه كانت في الاداره
الامريكيه على الورق بيحكوا كلام حلو ولكن
للاسف اسرائيل تستمر في اجرامها بسبب
الدعم الامريكي اذا امتلكت الاداره
الامريكيه الان الاراده لوقف هذا الاجرام
بحق الشعب الفلسطيني هنا انا بحكي لك
سيتحقق السلام الذي يحاول ان يعمل له
دعايه الان غوتشتاين امريكا بتحكي انه
الاستيطان عقبه وامس بلنكن اعلن عن منح
اسرائيل مليار دولار جديد لتسليحها وتسليح
القبه الحديديه
كل الشعب الفلسطيني اقتنع بانه كان من
الخطا الذهاب الى شرم الشيخ ومن الخطا
الاستمرار في التنسيق الامني ما هو معنى
التنسيق الامني عندما تختفي القوى الامنيه
من شوارع رام الله ويدخل جيش الاحتلال
بخمسين مدرعه ما معنى التنسيق الامني وما
قيمته ان كان عاجزا عن ان يدافع عن
الفلسطينيين في وجه المستوطنين المنفلتين
من عقالهم ويعتدون على الشعب الفلسطيني ما
يجب ان تفعل السلطه الفلسطينيه برايي ان
تتجه للوحده الوطنيه لتوحيد الصف الوطني
على برنامج وطني كفاحي مقاوم والتخلي عن
نهج التفاوض الذي فشل نحن كفلسطينيين
تعودنا بان لا نراهن على احد نحن نراهن
على انفسنا نروح على هؤلاء الشباب الاطفال
الشيوخ الذين تصدوا بالامس لقوات الاحتلال
نحن نراهن على ان نبقي قضيتنا حيه وتصل
الرساله الى العالم بعداله قضيتنا وبقبح
هذا الاحتلال دوله اسرائيل